we are talking about miss cardi being
last night she spoke only to ET about
the joys of her other full time gig I
love everything about motherhood I like
I like everything like it's just a
different feeling issue more of a
daddy's girl or a Mama's girl he thinks
mighty she loves me I love the more
variety she's just loyal to whoever
gives her the milk culture do you love
me I'm your mommy right now my baby
she's a little sick I'm up all night I'm
sucking her boogers it's a lot but I
love everything the 26 year old is so in
love with being a mom she and husband
offset are already thinking about giving
four month old culture a sibling how
many more I want two more but I don't
want them right now we caught up with
cardi at the star-studded launch of her
new line for fashion Nova which sold out
in under an hour it just feels good like
what other woman show love to each other
all love on the carpet but inside the
party there was drama
thanks to 15 year old Danielle Berg Olli
aka the cash may outside girl made
famous by the dr. Phil show ha ha bye
dad
the shade room caught the team trying to
drench rapper Iggy Azalea with her dream
as for Iggy's response she had this
message mama good luck with your career
you're young you're gonna look back on
this and you're gonna really feel dumb I
agree with you Iggy
[Music]